so P I'm gonna talk element wits for a
second I've heard that relative wits are
better suited for responsive design why
is that sure let's take a look at this
website for a second it's got a
beautiful panoramic image that's 1200
pixels wide on this laptop screen where
the viewport width is 1280 pixels no
problem the image fits just fine right
but now what happens if you shrink the
browser to a size that's below the image
is native width yeah if I'm not careful
instead of shrinking and rescaling the
image the image will keep its original
dimensions users will need to scroll
left and right to see the whole image
ooh that's ugly and annoying yeah it's
not a good experience on the Nexus 7
about a 30 the image is gonna get cut
off but on something like an iPhone 5
the users gonna see less than half the
image they're gonna have to scroll left
and right to see the whole thing since
CSS pixels vary so widely across all
these different devices you shouldn't
count on a specific viewport width for
your content to render well large CSS
widths or even absolute positions can
result in elements that are either too
big or don't fit on the screen at all
this is why you should use relative
positions instead of absolute position
such as width 100%